I'm Julia Brown and I'm an introvert I
am shy I'm Julia Brown and I'm an
introvert I had nothing to say I'm Julia
Elia Brown and I'm diamond introvert I'm
Annessa shy I'm Julia Pine Julia for I'm
in and I'm and I'm trying to shine me I
started to say I'm Julia Brian Julia I'm
entirely a brand I'm an introvert I know
I'm a surgeon I'm really a rapper I'm
Julie Dyer manager and I'm in a nice
experiment I social I'm Julia Brown and
I'm an introvert and I love meeting new
people but at the end of the day I need
my time to process to parse out what
I've learned and why it's important all
my life people have pushed me to be
somebody who I'm not but I know that a
smile from you is all the warmth and
recognition that I need in order to have
this discussion today I'd like you to
remember that introversion and
extraversion are on a scale we are all
somewhere in between 45% of today's
c-suite executives and over half the
population identify as introverts but no
one is 100% introverted or extroverted
the word introvert literally means to
turn inward and that's exactly what
introverts do in order to process the
day's events introverts turn to the
inner world of thought and feeling
rather than living in the moment
introverts focus on the meaning of
events and how that fits into the bigger
picture an introvert gains their energy
through reflection I'm Julia Brown and
I'm an introvert and this is my story
of breaking through the noise imagine
you've just walked off a plane and into
a foreign country it seems similar but
everything is slightly different the
street signs the smells of fried food
and cigarettes
the sounds of traffic from the main
thorough way or children playing in a
nearby school yard even the way the air
feels sticky on your skin
being an introvert is like walking into
a foreign country every day where you
where all of your senses are heightened
as you try to find your balance it's a
rush and the feeling of exhilaration and
adventure bubble up inside of you
it's a puzzle that you're struggling to
figure out but all of the pieces are
constantly moving and changing over time
you learn how it works
how it fits together and what to expect
I feel that way every time I walk into a
room full of new people or have to deal
with the new situation but that's also
how I survive walking off a plane into
Buenos Aires Argentina and apprenticea
myself to a chocolatier introverts have
the amazing ability to make their
friends acquaintances and colleagues
feel heard because they are listening
really closely to what you have to say
they're trying to figure out what makes
you you and why you do the things that
you do there's a reason nerdy awkward
Mark Zuckerberg invented the social
network it's because he knew what you
were gonna do before you did it yourself
I had studied Spanish in college but
nothing had prepared me for the
rapid-fire Spanish needed to work in an
Argentine kitchen being an introvert
surprisingly worked in my favor by by
closely watching and working with the
people around me I was able to learn
much more quickly how things should be
done how not to burn the chocolate how
long to let the ganache set for and the
delicate flick of the wrist needed to
make a design just so on the top of a
truffle even in a fast-paced loud
kitchen where pans are clattering the
radio is blaring Mahna and people are
shouting from one end of the kitchen to
the other you as an introvert can
connect with people on a deep and
personal level and break through the
noise after I was a chocolatier I became
a hedge fund analyst
it's a little bit of a career
non-sequitur I know but it's almost the
perfect job for an introvert you spend
all day reading the news industry
reports interviewing experts and
mom-and-pop business owners and then at
the end of the day you step back and you
distill that information into investable
ideas but the world of investing is a
world of noise the phones are constantly
raining CNBC is blasting behind you and
you feel as though you're living in a
perpetual earthquake where the next
piece of news could shatter the
foundations of your investment theses
your ideas the only way to survive in
this world is to have conviction a
belief so strong its interwoven with
your personality introverts are
naturally analytical by taking the time
to watch listen and process events they
can have contrarian unconventionals or
unconventional or even ahead of the
curve ideas but these same analytical
tendencies force you to recognize just
how fragile your ideas are you spend so
much time thinking about your ideas that
their flaws and cracks are obvious to
you and erode your conviction as an
introvert you have to fight this
tendency to turn inward to write off
your ideas because of their
imperfections as an introvert you have
to make yourself vulnerable these ideas
the ones that are integral to who we are
are the ones that we need to share with
the world the returns are worth the
risks Warren Buffett was a 25 year old
no name kid who couldn't get a job so he
started his own investment firm he
bought companies where nobody else saw
value today he's the greatest investor
of our time mr. Buffett is a
self-described introvert I started
working on a hedge fund as a 25 year old
no-name kid as a part-time office
manager within three years I was a
full-time analyst and two of the ideas I
had worked on where our two biggest
returns in the fund
I'm not saying I'm the next Warren
Buffett but I do know that having
conviction means knowing where the
limits of your belief system are I know
which events can render my ideas useless
and I can quantify that downside for you
but by knowing how large that downside
is I also know by how much the returns
outweigh that risk having conviction
means knowing that you might fail but
how much better it will be if you
succeed no your ideas be unconventional
break through the noise at this point
you're probably saying to yourself I've
heard all of this before I know it but
how do I actually get anyone to notice
how do I speak up it is impossible to
break through the noise without speaking
up believe me I've tried every way and
it's something I still struggle with
today which is why I'm here on a stage
in a roomful of people every day I
struggle to break through the noise of
my own self-doubt luckily I've had my
own champions my family friends and
mentors who were able to break through
my quiet and protected facade and find
something that they too believed in
these people have paved the way for me
to make some seemingly crazy choices
that turned out to be the best decisions
of my life these people pull me out of
my own protective cone of silence and
give me the strength to keep trying when
everything seems impossible find your
champions they will give you the power
to break through the noise in a world
that is constantly asking you to speak
up to make yourself vulnerable to make
yourself heard sometimes breaking
through the noise seems hard but it is
the perfect opportunity to rise to the
occasion and challenge yourself taking
this risk becomes
so much easier if you value yourself
know your skills you have the incredible
ability to make people feel heard in a
world where that's all anyone around you
is asking for and do you have the
ability to come up with creative outside
of the box ideas that can shatter the
limits of the world that we live in know
yourself challenge yourself trust
yourself break through the noise thank
you